how does a writer know that their
screenplay is ready for market is a very
good question I think the first thing
it's just really essential that a writer
submitted to colleagues for feedback and
I mean I am a professional in this field
a lot of times even though I am NOT a
writer I write treatments I work with
writers on treatments and Bibles and so
on and at a certain point I'll go
through multiple drafts I have a good
built-in sense of editing but at a
certain point you know I might think
this is great and then I'll send it to a
trusted colleague whether it's another
executive at a production company or a
writer whose opinion I respect and
they'll come back and I don't know if
they'll look my in my ass if I couldn't
say that but they'll come back with
feedback and go you know the the
treatment really isn't getting
interesting until page two so I would
cut out the first page in a half and you
know what it's so and it it's it makes
it better
and there are so I think are times where
if it's someone who is opinion you know
you need to really stay centered and on
point and I was something they
definitely feel strongly about for
writers is that especially in the notes
taking process because let's say a
writer sets up a project with a
production company studio or network and
they give notes one of the worst things
to do is to constantly be defending your
position and producers and executives
will start to feel you know what
life's too short this person isn't
receptive they're not fun to work with
they're not getting it they love it
everything they're doing you know what
I'm not going to renew or we're going to
replace the writer the best way for a
writer to be able to take notes is to be
totally open
and receptive and to try to hear like
what almost like with a second sense of
what the executive is trying to say so
let's say they say let me just think of
an example that I don't think a
character should you know say this line
they sound kind of mean right here and I
don't feel and then the writer if you're
listening rather than just defending it
you say oh that wasn't my attention I
was i meant that he was being defensive
and a little bit sarcastic but he was
kind of trying to be say it in a
charming way so then the executive would
say okay I get it now
but that wasn't coming through so then
the writer can see that their intention
wasn't coming across it that they would
go back and tweak it a bit so again I
think it's very important to stay like
you know true to your voice and not just
like roll over if someone says okay well
we have a an 85 year old protagonist and
and she has dementia but I decided that
I liked everything else about this story
but let's turn her into a thirteen year
old now and believe it or not I have
heard of situations not too far away
from that as a writer I think you need
to defend your position and why it was
essential to the story that that
character is was 85 with dementia that
might not be the best example but it's
basically a balance between maintaining
the integrity of your vision because you
can't just roll over for everything
because then you wind up with nothing
and you compromise artistry and any kind
of creative vision that you have but
anyway in terms of a writer knowing when
a project is ready I think that I hear a
lot of writers when I'm working with
them they'll say well there's always
going to be improvements to be made I
think when you are working with people
whether it's a strong script consultant
development executive friend who's maybe
a writer whose opinion you respect
development executive assistant to a
producer assistant to a writer director
and so on someone who's really
experienced with reading material and
knowing what Studios want that when it
gets to a point where there's less and
less notes and the collective feeling is
yeah there might be some work that still
needs to be done because there always
will be but it's good enough and for me
the bar of what's good enough is the
character that's that's well-developed
that's really coming through even if
there may be irascible or somewhat
unlikable that they we still can have
empathy for that character if they're a
villain it's still good to have some
empathy not always as important but for
your protagonist there's been a
distinction between sympathy what they
might do doesn't have to be sympathetic
but you should have a degree of empathy
for them and so I think it's it's really
when you're when the feedback comes back
pretty consistently that this is good
and you're not just looking for your
validation you have to be you know
really open
you